[Music]
mented furniture news Oh like when you
could put it in your room yeah
everything but no like future [ __ ] oh
cool
submitted by original hipster that's
what all hipsters what is an original
hipster he was like a hippie hippie and
like the first hipster hipsters used to
be like a compliment back of the day do
the hips it was a cool guy like that
what you're like whatever you mean like
those beatniks like those poetry ninja
movement they they were the best-dressed
the slick is like dope Jack Kerouac [ __ ]
yeah he was probably the first time so
how did that work come back because I
don't like that word I think it's like
people who are like trying to fake the
funk now yeah I mean like they big baby
they want to be so different and cool
there are like hippies that have that
are like leadest about technology and
the coffee in there and then they dress
like they're from the 1950s with the
curly mustaches engages so their
computer their comfy and they love
Edison light bulbs yeah but like no
[ __ ] religion dude they buy like a
empty warehouse space and put Edison
light bulbs in it they can never get a
[ __ ] light bulb at Home Depot ever
and by the way I love drinking out of
mason jars but not because of them but
because of barbeque restaurants so you
didn't [ __ ] put me on that [ __ ]
because there's so much liquid that can
be contained I love them it's actually
the same amount of liquid as a regular
cup no way do you tell them no when they
give you a big one they guess what big
[ __ ] one where it's a good gallon oh
when they give you a little one I hate
that [ __ ] why can't just let him believe
yeah she know she got a room trying to
run my dream this is crush I'm having a
good day
are you [ __ ] really Steve yeah it's
funny cause of the way he pitches it and
then people laugh she's pissed that
people get so much enjoyment from the
storm no because they exaggerates it to
get enjoyment out of the story I really
exaggerate guys I mean like laughs along
he laughs at his own self I was there
while you were crying about
I was those seats guys I feel like
there's some weird energy oh yeah you
guys just do it
let's try okay right now [ __ ] throw a
little bit of well this is weird same
but sighs y'all can argue down now y'all
I never left my throne and we haven't
even started this episode all right here
we go here we go I will say this film if
you want to be a jamali and here's what
you gotta do the story is funny thank
you there's no music over there thank
you
I don't have the balls okay so you think
I I think the stories funny because it's
not that expensive you it's because it's
committed such a dumb joke that's why
the stories play into this story though
yeah what the [ __ ] still the same over
there I love it I gotta BG oh yeah whole
animals animals your partner yeah you've
been mocking Jesus - oh yeah
[Applause]
we're such a good part we got to talk
about the article it's been like ten
minutes it's it writer predicts what our
homes will be like in the future
whoa you have such a cool job I feel
like we should switch seats okay yeah it
doesn't feel right just have fun so this
is what you see misinformation watch me
[ __ ] tell the story
real fast we built the pillow for it and
now there's so much depth there we go
it's a revelation over there
this story's about they're talking about
like homes in the future and what
they're saying is like have you guys
heard of those the hollow glasses of
micro Microsoft Oh like Google glass
microsoft's hololens where's your shades
it's like those kind of but like an
actual whole thing and what it does is
it creates like holograms in front of
you awesome and like people can like
work on it like for developers and stuff
like that Wow
and then there's this other one called
magic leap that kind of just similar
things but it's like direct retinal
projection whatever that means so it's
like you could see things in your the
room that you're standing in but I
projected kinda like a are like what
they did with Tupac yeah that's cool by
the way thank you
two packs two patches I've seen one
where they they had a like a full city
like done holo style like on a tape big
date they've projected like a like onto
a blank table like a full city like AR
style like what you're talking about
it was super sick look you see that it
was like a Microsoft demonstration or
something I think what you're talking
about I saw this thing when we were in
Houston they actually had oh and in New
York they had these buildings but they
were like white buildings like in like
physical white little miniature
buildings but then they projected the
actual city on it and it looked at me
yeah I was pretty crazy that's really
cool so what they're saying here is that
in the future instead of buying a new
couch you could just upload an image
on to your old one and it look new it's
not gonna work cuz what if somebody pees
on your couch you're still gonna smell
like [ __ ] I was thinking of the
logistics of this too I'm like like what
they're just gonna sell like IKEA
furniture we're just like all white and
then you upload image and then you have
to turn on the projection you have to
always have it have it on right I think
in the future like eventually won't we
won't need if they have like contacts or
something embedded in our eyes or I feel
like it'll be the actual furniture
itself I just looks like you don't think
you look at your movies it means
rejected inside to them that's so sick
but then like when you're sitting on it
wouldn't it like the all [ __ ] up I
agree you know were you moving your face
and it stays on to your face but then
sometimes it pops off so you see like
it's a piece of [ __ ] have you seen the
[ __ ] where you can turn an object
invisible by projecting the surrounding
areas it's really cool [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah they mean like coats and [ __ ] like
there's like a Japanese raincoat or
whatever
developed by DARPA weird I think where
they they you can wear like a ghillie
suit almost and it projects like uh like
the like moss covered suit that way
where so it's like Harry Potter's
clothes it's exactly like that and you
can kind of see them like yeah but if
they're just projecting the surroundings
that's so cool
technology's gonna be crazy just like a
mirror oh man yeah and then they're
saying like you know with the hats the
housing demand and like with the rapid
population growth like pretty much in
the future we're gonna be living in
smaller and smaller places because the
population just keeps growing I hope not
and it's like super expensive to own
anything so they're saying like now like
gold not now but in the future it will
just be super easy to just have like a
small collection of essential furniture
items that are like blink pieces I guess
and then you can just project like what
you want to change on it and you also
don't need to worry about having windows
because you could just project a
beautiful dough like that like what I
want there's always gonna be cancers
that are like now this is original I'm
an actress
just a window or nature no yeah what's
up I'm a hipster it's not a wheelchair
people are like once you get this
projection and they're like it's not a
projection bro it's authentic vintage
that's like rich people they hire hot
ladies to be tables and stuff you don't
want a hologram we were at a party one
time was a lady who was a sushi met oh
yeah do that
you want to be a sushi girl I want to
eat sushi no I don't like eating the
fish you wanted to lay there be a table
we can set it up so I could pay me to
lay the [ __ ] down
hell yeah okay I pay you to lay down
that's the only drawback you can't
scratch your nose and then the more you
think about it the more you know it just
makes me want to do it because you're a
lot of sushi buddy's gonna hit the
ground $13.32 around $300 at sushi yeah
you're pyrite oh that's all right I
remember and your body warmth is
supposed to keep the rice at the right
temperature some example you think it
would want the fish do then no the fish
isn't oh I didn't know that it's about
the body warmth sushi rice is supposed
to be about the same temperature of your
body it's like a warm chair after
someone I kind of like that though like
one I like it yeah because you know when
we buy the bidet it comes with the seat
that can be pretty good because it's
like okay he feels the same though and
you don't know if it was the machine
that preheated the toilet seat or if
someone's asking the machines hotter
it's the same [ __ ] I like it to burn my
aspiration yeah me too have you guys
ever use of a date in like the
wintertime and like the water supposed
to be a little warmer but it comes out
cold you're just like holy [ __ ] you can
keep it warm I know that's what I'm
saying it was supposed to be warm but
then the initial thing was like it's
kind of sexual yeah I wasn't expecting
that so hyper Barney did it's really
awesome
why are you so horny no you are [ __ ]
every episode
you found something to be turned on
about point O so proud look at him over
there I don't want a future house I want
a primitive house I know you want a mud
hut yep you're a hipster now tit I'm
beyond hipster legit homeless isn't it
I want fake future everything dude like
it's like Vegas
give me that yeah like all the
technology like I have those the light
bulbs that you could turn off with like
that the Apple home thingy I could turn
it off with my watch that's it dude you
hear about Bill Gates's house where so
they were they where what's called power
cards which which like they let you have
a room set to your own personal settings
yeah well that's like near walls change
colors yeah music comes on yeah [ __ ]
yeah like the the temperature or
whatever the [ __ ] setting you like the
lights whatever you like they smell like
lavender or vanilla some shut-eye also
he has like um like screens on the wall
that like the pictures load or like
people live in his house he has a family
like a father when your eyes start
hurting like you're looking at phone
screen too long if that was on your wall
all the time I don't give a [ __ ] so I
was thinking about when I watch the
black mirror episode when they made it
look like a you know meadow or whatever
I want a house that Dee folds like a
dome Rob as you don't listen to him what
a dream killer [ __ ] up I could
technically walk outside but it feels
better when you hit a button and it goes
bang yeah and then it's just the bed and
then the whole [ __ ] air and every oh
that's it I like that like if you watch
the what's that one we like to watch the
extreme homes or what extreme oh no we
don't special beyond like craziest homes
in the world ourselves
yeah but like there's ones where they're
in the military bad market making
do they have bad marketing a shower but
like it's all open and everything but no
one can see you because there's nobody
there you never trust that you could
tell me there's not a few human soul in
like 10,000 miles and I still won't
shower chef before we go to the Korean
spa and you get naked in front of all
those [ __ ] but that's different she
likes getting naked in front of women
well what if you have a homie them like
a [ __ ] radar and it goes baby I
really liked it there was this spa that
I had very old ain't coming dick they
want Tiff's nude so bad they hack the
radar like a hundred miles in
civilization it's about the fact that I
did not give them permission she's like
this is private there's like no one for
miles of mine
this is private private nobody there
she's mad at the armadillo that [ __ ]
looks yeah he scurries
[Music]